صور ولقطات صادمه ليست بالامر الجديد في
ممارسات الاحتلال في الاراضي المحتله
لكنها تكرار لا يقتل هول الصدمه في كل مره
ومنذ ساعات الفجر الاولى والمواقف تتتابع
بين رفض وادانه ومطالبه بالمحاسبه وترد
اسرائيل
باحاله تفضي الى تحميل اخرين المسؤوليه
تاره واثاره اخرى بناء ينافي واقع الحال
المثبت بالصوره والصوت اريد هذا وذاك يخيم
القلق على المدينه المقدسه املا في شهر
مبارك يعمه الامن لابنائها
في التفاصيل دنى المندوب الفلسطيني لدى
الامم المتحده رياض منصور اعتداء قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على المصلين في
المسجد الاقصى وقال منصورنا بلاده دعت الى
عقد بوشاورات مغلقه لمجلس الامن غدا
الخميس لمناقشه الموضوع
هذا العدوان الاثم من قبل سلطات الاحتلال
والمستوطنين والمتطرفين الذين يريدوا ان
يفرضوا تقسيما زمانيا ومكانيا على المسجد
الاقصى الامر الذي لن يتم بفضل جهود وصمود
اهلنا في القدس الذين نحييهم ونشد على
اياديهم ونقول لهم على انه واجبنا ان
نسندهم وندعمهم وان نطلب من المجتمع
الدولي وفي المقدمه من قبل مجلس الامن ان
يتحملوا مسؤولياتهم في هذا الشان
هذا وكان المبعوث الربمي الى الشرق الاوسط
قد قال انه فزع من صور العنف داخل المسجد
القبلي في الاقصى وعرب المبعوث عن رفضه
بشده لمواصفه بتخزين واستخدام الالعاب
الناريه والحجاره من قبل الفلسطينيين داخل
المسجد ودعا المبعوثه القاده من جميع
الاطراف الى رفض الخطاب التحريضي والاعمال
الاستفزازيه وتصرف بمسؤوليه والامتناع عن
الخطوات التي يمكن ان تصعد التوترات
وامريكيا قال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه
بمجلس الامن القوميه الامريكيه جون كيربي
ان الولايات المتحده تشعر بقلق بالغ بسبب
ما سماه العنف المستمر بين الطرفين
الاسرائيلي والفلسطيني واقل كيربي انه
عاصم قلقه للغايه بسبب استمرار العنف في
المسجد الاقصى
وفي ردود الفعل الدوليه اعرب رئيس الوزراء
الكندي
جاستنت برودو عن قلق بلاده من الخطاب
التصعيدي الصادري من الحكومه الاسرائيليه
حسب تعبيرهم
وتعليقا على احداث الاقصى قال رئيس
الوزراء الكندي ان بلاده ان نرى تغييرا في
نهج الحكومه الايطاليه كما دنت جامعه
الدول العربيه اقتحام الاقصى وشددت
الجامعه على ان هذه التصرفات غير المسؤوله
تمسوا المشاعر الدينيه لملايين المسلمين
ودعت المجتمع الدوليه للتحرك بسرعه من اجل
دفع اسرائيل لوقف هذا صيد الخطير وحضرت
الجامعه العربيه من غبه تصدير الازمه
السياسيه الداخليه في اسرائيل الى الشعب
الفلسطيني واكدتنا ان التوجهات المتطرفه
التي تتحكم في سياسه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
سوف تقود الى مواجهات واسعه مع
الفلسطينيين اذا لم يوضع حد
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه قد وصفت ما تقوم به
قوات الاحتلال من مساس بالمقدسات بانه حرب
شعواء على الشعب الفلسطيني والامه العربيه
وعلى ذلك سيشعل الحرائق في المنطقه وفقرها
وحملت رئاسه الفلسطينيه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه كامل المسؤوليه عن اي تدهور
قد يحصل ودعتها الى وقف ما وصفته بالعبث
الذي ستكون له نتائج خطيره على الجبهه
من جهه قال رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه
حماس اسماعيلانيه انما يجري في الاقصى
المبارك جريمه غير مسبوقه ولها ما بعدها
اما الامير العام للجهاد الاسلامي زياد
النخاله فقال ان على الشعب الفلسطيني ان
يكون حاضرا بكل مكوناته للمواجهه الحتميه
مع الاحتلال في الايام القادمه على حد
تعبيره
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
علق بان حكومته تعمل للحفاظ على الوضع
الراهن وتهدئه الموقف بعد الاحداث في
المسجد الاقصى الا ان وزير الامن القوميه
تمار بين غفير دعا الحكومه للرد بقوه على
اطلاق صواريخ من غزه وليس بقصف اماكن غير
ماهوله وفق قوله اما وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي يا اسرائيل
فدعى الجيش الى شن ما سماها عمليه السور
الواقي اثنان في الضفه الغربيه وان تبدا
بنابلس وجنين
من جهته قال رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي
هيرسي ان الاحداث في الاقصى زادت التوتر
في غزه والضفه ان اي صاروخ يطلق نحو
اسرائيل سيقابل برد مناسب وفعال وفق تع